pour en parler votre invité ce matin
Geneviève Darrieux sac ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous je suis
très heureuse de vous recevoir ce matin
un grand plaisir pour moi aussi alors
vous êtes depuis un an le 4 juillet 22
pratiquement enfin bientôt un an
ministre délégué en charge des personnes
handicapées alors pouvez-vous rapidement
parce que j'ai plein d'autres questions
pour vous mais pour vous rapidement nous
rappeler les contours de ce ministère
ou bien ils sont clairs ça concerne tous
les sujets
des personnes en situation de handicap
et de leur famille sachant qu'en fait
mon mon travail est passionnant parce
qu'il est un terme ministériel je
travaille avec tous mes collègues
ministres en fait la politique de
handicap ne doit pas être une politique
à part on veut l'inclusion des personnes
en situation de handicap dans notre
société il faut donc que toutes les
politiques les concernent les politiques
éducatives l'éducation nationale le
travail aujourd'hui enfin j'ai présenté
récemment des mesures dans le le ce sens
là avec Olivier du socle voilà toutes
les politiques les politiques du sport
les politiques culturelles donc nous
sommes vraiment je suis présente auprès
de mes collègues en permanence et je
leur demande dans tous les projets de
loi qu'ils peuvent envisager élaborer de
toujours penser à la part qui revient
aux personnes en situation de handicap
alors moi à titre personnel j'ai
toujours cette question sur
l'interministérialité parce que en fait
évidemment ça concerne énormément le
ministère mais chaque ministère a ses
projets à sa mission est-ce que cette
interministérialité elle est plutôt
positive sur des sujets comme celui-là
je crois qu'elle était essentielle déjà
à titre symbolique c'est ce que je vous
disais en préambule c'est à dire que ces
personnes les personnes en situation de
handicap
ont dans le droit dans leurs droits
doivent participer entièrement à notre
société et de façon active et doivent
être reçus dans notre société de façon
active donc à l'école et bien tout ce
qui concerne l'école au concerne aussi
les les jeunes en situation de handicap
dans le monde du travail de la formation
professionnelle et du travail c'est
aussi le cas
dans tous les ponts de notre société
nous avons leur parcours de vie est un
parcours de vie de comme tout citoyen et
doit s'intégrer dans cette dynamique
alors bien sûr
il y a des politiques particulières qui
sont plus portés au niveau de mon
ministère c'est la politique de la
protection ou de l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap et
les plus sévères alors les
établissements qui reçoivent ces
personnes ou les services
d'accompagnement qui sont mises en œuvre
pour les accompagner à leur domicile ou
dans leur lieu de vie mais voilà tout
cela fait partie d'une politique qui
doit être d'ailleurs
qui doit être dans tous les ministères
et d'ailleurs nous avons deux fois par
an comme un comité interministériel du
handicap afin de tracer la voix de
chaque pour chaque ministre on fait le
bilan de ce qui a été mis en oeuvre et
on trace la voie pour la suite alors en
2019 la loi pour une société inclusive a
été adoptée et une récente étude de la
commission nationale à consultative des
droits de l'homme et en Isère et des
constats assez préoccupants 64% des
personnes interrogées estiment que le
handicap est un obstacle au bonheur et
la vie épanouie 35% des moins de 35 ans
sont David que les personnes en
situation de handicap ne sont pas
capables de travailler contre 19% pour
la population générale 31% estiment
qu'il voudrait mieux éviter qu'une
personne handicapée et des enfants et
des élèves et 46% déclarent qu'il serait
inquiet sur leur enfance marié avec une
personne en situation de handicap alors
quel est votre regard personnel sur la
progression de l'inclusion et la prise
en compte de la diversité des personnes
en situation de handicap aujourd'hui
vous soulevez dans votre question
quelque chose qui est majeur et que je
je dis quotidiennement c'est que
l'inclusion ne doit pas venir que d'une
espèce de d'obligation qui serait faite
par les politiques d'inclure dans la
société l'inclusion il faut que la
société aussi évolue pour que la
représentation évolue il faut que le
handicap soit compris aujourd'hui le
handicap 80% des handicaps sont
invisibles et sont bien souvent inconnus
mal connus certains disent ça fait peur
et je pense que on a une partie une
grande partie de notre société qui vit
dans l'ignorance ce n'est pas de la
mauvaise volonté c'est de l'ignorance de
la méconnaissance de ces sujets de
handicap de ce qui est autiste de ce
qu'est
un jeune avec des troubles psychiques de
ce qu'est la déficience intellectuelle
donc c'est représentations et bien il
faut que nous les effassions c'est
représentation négative afin de pouvoir
travailler justement sur cette inclusion
enfin l'inclusion c'est une société qui
est suffisamment accessible et qui
accueille tous dans leur diversité oui
mais ça veut dire qu'on est non progrès
à faire parce que les campagnes
communication sont nombreuses et
malheureusement on n'a pas tout à fait
avancé alors j'ai un peu j'ai envie
surtout maintenant de vous parler de des
femmes handicapées on en a trois un peu
plus de 3 millions en France une femme
sur cinq a déjà été victime de viol donc
les femmes en situation de handicap sont
deux fois plus nombreuses à avoir subi
des violences sexuelles que les femmes
non handicapées comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cela
je pense que c'est une deux sujets il y
a le sujet de la vulnérabilité et bon ce
sont souvent l'affaire de de prédateurs
de dominateurs qui cherchent des
personnes vulnérables d'une part et puis
pour certains il y a aussi le pour
certaines il y a aussi le sujet de la
méconnaissance de ce qu'est le
consentement de la méconnaissance de ce
qui leur corps de la méconnaissance de
ce que sont des relations sexuelles
normales consenties donc on a vraiment
un énorme travail à faire dans ce
domaine là aussi et dans ce sens nous
avons mis en place un dispositif qui
s'appelle Andy gynéco qui en fait est
porté par des sages-femmes ou des
médecins gynécologues qui vont par
exemple dans des établissements pour
personnes handicapées et qui
font bien entendu des examens donnent un
accès aux examens gynécologiques ce qui
est très important mais également à la
parole et bien c'est là que on se rend
compte qu'il y a des violences sexuelles
à l'intérieur de de d'établissement mais
également travaillent font de la
formation auprès des personnes
handicapées des femmes en situation de
handicap mais aussi des hommes qui sont
quelquefois dans les mêmes
établissements pour leur donner la
notion de ce qu'est un corps humain de
ce que sont des relations sexuelles de
ce qu'est le consentement donc nous
avons aussi un grand travail à faire
dans ce domaine là on travaille il est
parce que les violences c'est un
continuum on est bien d'accord
31% des femmes handicapées ont fait
l'objet de contact physique au travail
20% pour l'ensemble des femmes 35%
déclare avoir été victime de violence
conjugales en fait est-ce qu'on peut
espérer un changement comment est-ce
qu'on peut réellement faire bouger les
choses oui et un chiffre que vous n'avez
pas donné 90% des femmes autistes qui
ont subi des violences sexuelles c'est
absolument terrifiant terrifiant donc et
bien je crois qu'il faut en parler
il faut d'abord ouvrir la parole il faut
donner la possibilité à ces personnes
qui n'ont pas toujours une communication
classique de pouvoir s'exprimer de
pouvoir mettre des quelquefois des
images sur des mots qu'elles ont
qu'elles ont subi des mots mex
et qu'elle puisse communiquer parce que
ce sont souvent les problèmes de
communication qui font que
les choses ne sont pas connues et ne
sont pas prises en compte donc nous
avons véritablement besoin de de faire
cet immense travail de savoir écouter
ces personnes de savoir reconnaître les
signaux faibles et de pouvoir à partir
de ces signaux faibles et bien entendre
leurs paroles quand elles annoncent et
quand elles n'ont pas de pouvoir
décrypter ce qu'elle disent à partir de
de
de dessin de choses qui sont
relativement comme les enfants un petit
peu quelquefois c'est il faut savoir
écouter cette parole il faut savoir
l'accepter il faut surtout la prendre en
compte et ne pas penser que ce sont
voilà que c'est négligeable et je crois
que tout cela est essentiel et puis
ensuite bien sûr pouvoir porter plainte
pouvoir avoir des actions pénales quand
cette nécessaire parce qu'on a parlé
d'établissement mais on peut parler des
violences intrafamilales également qui à
mon avis sont aussi très préoccupantes
alors sur les établissements les
établissements qui accueillent ces
personnes les établissements qui sont
censés les protéger
on sait qu'il y a de très nombreux
dysfonctionnements maltraitance
négligence qui conduisent à ces
solutions complètement à ces situations
complètement inacceptables pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à créer de
meilleures conditions de sécurité dans
ces lieux de vie pour vous bon moi
d'abord je voudrais je voudrais pas
qu'on mettre l'eau propre sur toutes les
personnes qui travaillent dans le
médico-social parce que
majorité de tout ce qui travaille dans
ce secteur sont des personnes au
contraire qui font un travail absolument
extraordinaire et d'accompagnement et
nous avons vraiment besoin d'aide dans
leur dans leur compétences et dans leur
bienveillance mais il peut y avoir
effectivement des des bons voilà des
personnes maltraitantes je crois que il
ne faut surtout pas s'habituer il faut
que bien la parole se libère aussi dans
les établissements c'est à dire qu'on
soit capable de dire que telle personne
n'agit pas bien pour les personnes en
s'occuper il faut être capable
d'entendre cela et de pouvoir prendre
toute mesure bien sûr pour éloigner ces
personnes il faut que nous puissions et
moi ça me semble essentiel dans tous les
recrutements dans ces établissements
pouvoir avoir aussi vérifier
l'honorabilité des personnes recrutées
et pour moi c'était absolument essentiel
parce que avec des personnes vulnérables
les choses sont
euh difficile enfin je veux dire c'est
essentiel qu'il y a de l'honorabilité
dans le profil des personnes recrutées
donc une vigilance accrue toutes ces
mesures et bien sûr
on vous dira suffisamment de de
personnels pour entourer
ces personnes alors il y a une
différence en fait une différence pour
moi c'est toujours de la violence mais
entre ce qui certains parlent de
maltraitance parce qu'il y a pas
suffisamment de personnel pour entourer
les personnes ils ont le sentiment de
mal faire leur travail le mal faire cet
accompagnement ça c'est une chose que
l'on règle en modifiant les en ayant
plus de personnel peut-être mais aussi
en modifiant les méthodes de travail
mais il y a aussi la les violences qui
sont qui peuvent être assénés et il faut
être
intransigeant intransigeant je le dis y
compris pour ceux qui les collègues de
travail qui voit cela ça ne peut pas on
ne peut pas rester insensible et on ne
peut pas se taire devant ce type de
choses alors vous êtes né dans les
Landes vous êtes issu d'une famille
Agricole vous avez exercé pendant 25 ans
le métier de médecin allergologue engagé
aussi dans la vie associative moi j'ai
envie de dire que vous avez toujours été
ancré dans les réalités vous avez
commencé votre carrière politique en
2004 à 48 ans si des informations sont
les bonnes et c'est le cas conseillère
départemental député des Landes de
montrer au gouvernement 2017 vous avez
été aussi secrétaire d'État près d'un
ministre des Armées ministre déléguées
chargées de la mémoire des anciens
combattants toutes les personnes qui
vous côtoient vous disent attaché au
terrain au dialogue à la modération
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
y a une omerta face à ces violences
faites aux pensées en handicapés comment
vous vous est-ce que vous avez été
empêché ou pas ou ce que vous avez le
sentiment que finalement cette action
elle est possible et elle est réelle
pour vous
je pense que aujourd'hui pour avoir un
peu vulnérain je pense que c'est quelque
chose dont on ne parle pas assez dans le
milieu du handicap
oui peut-être une omerta c'est peut-être
on est peut-être un peu la poussière
sous le tapis donc
moi je crois que ça je ne peux pas m'y
résoudre donc je souhaiterais que l'on
en parle quand il faut en parler que
l'on dénonce les choses si elles
existent bien entendu et surtout que
l'on règle les situations donc oui il
faut agir moi je suis écouté moi j'ai
toujours été très engagé pour le respect
des personnes quelle qu'elle soit quelle
qu'elle soit et le respect des personnes
et le droit des personnes en situation
de handicap c'est de vivre pleinement
leur vie de la vivre le plus sereinement
possible et de la vivre le mieux
accompagné possible et je ne me
résoudrai jamais à voilà à laisser
passer des situations de violence quelle
qu'elle soit notamment à l'égard de ces
personnes